william is devastated by this interview
on tuesday cbs morning anchor gail king
who is a close friend of oprah winfrey
and attended meghan markle's baby shower
when she was pregnant with archie
opened up on the morning news program
about a conversation
she says she had with megan and prince
harry following their interview with
oprah that aired earlier this month well
i'm not trying to break news but i did
actually call them to see how they were
feeling and it's true
harry has talked to his brother and he
has talked to his father too
the word i was given was that the those
conversations were
not productive but they are glad that
their they have at least started a
conversation and now a source is telling
et
prince william is deeply distressed that
the couple decided to share
private family conversations with gail
the talk at the palace is that they are
absolutely horrified by what has been
said they feel that
harry has literally thrown the family
under a bus
during the tell-all interview with oprah
megan alleged that william's wife kate
middleton
made her cry leading up to her royal
wedding over a situation surrounding
flower girl dresses
and while the former suit star later
said kate apologized with flowers
and is a quote good person e.t source
says william is fiercely protective of
kate
and was unhappy that megan talked about
his wife judging from
the reaction from what he said from the
huge repercussions that this interview
has had
any healing is going to take a very long
time and i think what feels
so sad is that he was just getting
family relations back on track he had he
wasn't speaking to his brother for a
long time
they were back in touch william is is
devastated by this interview don't
forget the duchess of cambridge has been
dragged into this
whole saga and william will will hate
that
as for the queen the source says the
whole situation
has been very upsetting for her e.t has
also learned that harry and megan had
hoped that discussions with the royal
family would lead to healing
but for now the couple is staying
focused on their charitable work
smartworks charity one of megan's former
royal patronages
that provides interview training and
clothing to help women find employment
or get back into the workplace
shared several sweet handwritten letters
of encouragement
the duchess of sussex penned to women
interviewing for
and receiving jobs in one letter she
wrote quote
i wanted to offer my personal
congratulations on landing a new
position in public health
i can't think of anything more important
right now and i'm so pleased to know
that smartworks supported you
in the lead up to your successful job
interview the organization also revealed
that the notes were sent from megan's
home in montecito california
to the uk where they were then packaged
with some of the interview attire sent
to the recipients
but back to that penmanship prior to her
life as a royal
megan actually made money as a pro
calligrapher
she had this beautiful writing i was
like and at that moment i feel like i
said something to her like you are meant
to be like roy or be of this kind
yes megan even did the invites for robin
thicke
and paula patton's 2005 wedding and
showed off her skills
on the spot during a 2013 interview with
larry king oh look at that
look at that oh dude